limpieza en París al día siguiente de
una manifestación masiva contra la
reforma de pensiones los escombros
alrededor de este kiosco destruido son
prueba de la violencia que tuvo lugar
durante la movilización ya se han
llevado a cabo 9 días de movilizaciones
declaradas pero también hay
concentraciones improvisadas y banda Los
mezclados entre los manifestantes la
policía endurece su respuesta luego de
que se conoció que el Rey Carlos III
aplazó su visita a Francia el presidente
de Manuel macron no ha parado de
condenar la violencia en una democracia
no tenemos derecho a la violencia y Por
tanto se exigen nuestras fuerzas
policiales el pleno respeto a la
deontología con la transparencia y el
examen que debe acompañarlo Pero esto no
lo pongo en paralelo con lo que ocurre
en la sociedad No cederemos a la
violencia y la condeno con la mayor
firmeza
el diario lemont reveló una secuencia de
más de 20 minutos grabada por un grupo
de personas detenidas en la que se
escuchan bofetadas y amenazas de los
agentes de policía en un comunicado
citando a su presidenta el consejo de
Europa el principal organismo de defensa
de Derechos Humanos en el Continente
manifestó su preocupación por el uso
excesivo de la fuerza contra los
manifestantes
se han producido incidentes violentos
algunos de ellos dirigidos contra
agentes del orden pero los actos
esporádicos de violencia por parte de
algunos manifestantes u otros actos
reprobables cometidos por otras personas
durante una manifestación no pueden
justificar el uso excesivo de la fuerza
por parte de los agentes del estado
estos actos tampoco bastan para privar a
los manifestantes pacíficos del Disfrute
del derecho a la libertad de reunión
según el Ministerio del interior 441
agentes del orden resultaron heridos
durante las manifestaciones del jueves
en una jornada que dejó al menos 457
personas arrestadas